well I always said you make a great case
you know I saw you debating to santis I
said you know I'm trying to get this guy
to run for president for a long
time he looks like he'd be very good at
it what I liked with that also is you're
you're kind of mean and we need that you
know when you need to be not over the
top but I was on I appreciate that I was
on kbla yeah the other day yesterday
with my friend Tavis Smiley I'm an
investor and a supporter of that station
and I you know he said who do you want
for R president I mentioned I think you
be good at the job not this year we
know um no I know um but he said uh I
don't think he could win I don't think
he could win he's too Progressive coming
from this state and what he's done in
this state to win in any uh Southern
State any Red State I disagreed but no
this is a progressive African-American
owned station and they I'm sure they
like you but he doesn't think you can
win what do you say to that when you
when you're if you could win the look at
the the the uh wing state there's only
eight of them right well I mean
California is an interesting case study
isn't it it's the size of 21 State
populations combined yeah uh two-thirds
the state is very deeply read uh we
don't need to be lectured on Rural uh
politics or border issues I mean in so
many ways these are familiar issues and
the issues of the heartland of the
United States are very much a part and
parcel of the work we're doing in this
state but look I understand this notion
that you're from the coast you don't
understand those things you can't talk
the language you're not able to
communicate uh and you're not able to
actually encourage and that no it's
stuff like there's a new law in this I
think we have way too many regulations
and laws as we've talked about and this
one I think says if you're a department
store with
over 500 employees you have to have a
gender neutral toy department yeah stuff
like that yeah I get it so do you think
that's silly do you think that's a silly
thing that that we too much government
too much government there that look that
that's an interesting one because the
department stores came to us supporting
that and they're the ones making a case
for that uh they were making Cas they're
already moving in that direction wanted
you make a law about them well they they
but they supported the legislation
wasn't legislation that was enacted that
was initiated uh from my office but it
was legislation that came up with
interesting support from the industry
itself but I understand how that's
exploited and good people can disagree
but that's not something we woke up and
said this is a top priority for the
state when we know the top priorities
the homelessness housing the issues of
crime quality of life and issues related
to regulation and taxes which are all
top of mind but I get how those things
are a weapon all right so when I got you
here cuz I live here and I'm not going
anywhere so I just want to make this a
better State like everybody else and
good job this year making it rain you're
welcome that was uh that was uh yeah
because that was my legislative priority
it was looking bad there for a while and
we still don't have enough water in the
Colorado River and all this stuff and
then whenever I read 80% of the water
goes to agriculture almonds no one ever
asked you about almonds oh I'm going to
ask you about
almonds we grow a boatload of alond I'm
well aware you know you know how much
how many how much water it takes many
gallons 1900 gallons to grow a pound of
almonds we come on man take take on big
almonds take on big
almonds I mean it's it's not like we
don't have the water no but what you're
right about it's not that we don't have
the water that said you know the last
couple years were tough I mean it's but
it's also where the water is falling and
we're not capturing it and we're not
capturing in those extreme years with
these atmospheric Rivers wets are
getting a lot wetter drri is drier Hots
getting a lot hotter and so we've got to
modernize our conveyance system we've
got to modernize our storage not just
above ground but below ground and so
that's a big part of our focus and frame
including desalinization plants we have
20 projects just on diesel that we're
working on today so we've been we put
out a detailed water Strat strategy that
includes by the way getting that Delta
conveyance project back up and
operational and includes the first above
ground off stream uh storage facility in
half a century in the state which by the
way is being aided by a regulatory
package I push forward to reduce red
tape in the state of California and
dress the Perman quag Mars that you
rightfully pointed
out say
here you're good at this see I'm telling
you you're good at this job okay
but but but here's I feel like the last
couple of years you've like purposely
picked this fight with the red States I
mean the S yeah but I don't want I don't
want to live in the Civil War I agree
with that you know what but you seem
like you you purposely want to set up
this this dichotomy between oh this is a
blue State and that's a red State and
and I don't want to live in that country
I like Florida I'm with you and by the
way I I I I like Florida as well like I
like all these states I I completely
agree I don't want to have a state of
mind that's a constant fight and flight
we've gone through so much we've been
polarized and traumatized there's been a
tough five six years across the globe
not just in this country that said I'm
not going to sit back and watch and you
made the point just a moment ago in your
monologue you got folks out there trying
to bring us back to a pre-1960s world
America in Reverse rolling back voting
rights lgbtq rights women's rights not
just access to abortion but
contraception I it's a profound and
consequential moment and you could sit
by and well I really want to get along
as these guys are rolling back the clock
or you can stand tall and assert
yourself and the reason I started to go
into those red States the reason I
started take on to santis and the reason
I started doing ads in these red States
is I didn't felt my party was doing
enough it was CRT one year and then it's
ESG and it's Dei anything with three
letters these guys keep coming and
they're shape shifting and they're
they're try so but it's true right and
and and so and I just thought there was
a little timidity in our party and I
thought we need to call this stuff out
these guys are being on a Banning binge
across this country you want to talk
about cancel culture look at the
Republican Party ask Bud Light Target
Disney that's just the private sector
Banning speech not in just in the
classroom but in the boardroom as it
relates to issues arace look what
they've done
3,362 books just last year they're
banning this is a serious and
consequential moment it's the cultural
Purge that's going on in this country
and so I just felt like we needed to
call that out as Democrats and put them
on the defense since we're consistently
on our heels as a Democratic party even
though I think the facts bear out our
case significantly better than the case
on the other
side but again uh bill I say all that
with with love in my heart with love in
my heart and I mean that I mean I don't
talk down to people I don't want to talk
past people I I everyone wants to be
respected connected and and protected
and we all want to be loved and need to
be loved I'm with you on all that at the
same time man when you're going after
the LGBT community and talking down to
people and humiliating folks you're
threatening to sue uh the special
Olympians when you're going after the
black community and trying to rewrite
history and saying slavery somehow with
some Workforce Development program damn
it we have to call that stuff
out off my high
horse can can you teach that speech to
Biden
that